et étant donné la thématique de la
semaine ma question concerne la
francophonie mais en un préambule je
voudrais quand même vous dire que je
suis relativement marquée par l'absence
volontaire du premier ministre
aujourd'hui dans nos rangs voici un an
sous la coupole de l'institut de france
le prendre la république prononcé un
discours relatifs à la francophonie
après avoir partagé la conception de ce
qu'est aujourd'hui la francophonie c'est
à dire cette langue française devenue le
centre de toutes les nations et de tous
les peuples où elle fait souche dans sa
variété
le chef de l'état a fixé un cap
apprendre échanger et créer en français
outre ces engagements il s'est projeté
au-delà de nos frontières il a souhaité
que la france puisse à travers son aide
publique au développement
réaffirmer son engagement fort pour
l'éducation à cet engagement en matière
de développement
le panda public a également annoncé des
mesures concrètes notamment en proposant
à volontariat international pour le
français et un doublement des missions
du service civique sur cet enjeu en
annonçant un nouvel élan pour les lycées
français et un doublement du nombre
d'élèves inscrits dans le réseau
scolaire d'ici 2025 et en demandant à
nos établissements du supérieur de
s'implanter hors de nos frontières et de
se regrouper en campus
l'ambition est importante il a également
ajouté de nouvelles missions aux acteurs
de l'audiovisuel francophone et un
nombre d'institutions qu'il faut
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde
vive la francophonie or à ce jour le
vantail internationale n'est toujours
pas mis en place les budgets alloués à
la fois aux alliances françaises au
lycée sont en diminution et
l'audiovisuel consacré à la francophonie
est en plein doute
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous dire un an après ce grand discours
quelles sont les actions du gouvernement
pour traduire les nombreux engagements
annoncés dont vous répandre la parole et
à monsieur jean baptiste le voile
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
europe et des affaires étrangères vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur mouillé je salue
également le vice président délégué de
la section française de l'assemblée
parlementaire de la francophonie je le
signale parce que ce sont les parlements
qui
été pionnier avant les gouvernements et
nous avons fêté en 2017 et 50 ans de la
pf alors un an après le grand le
discours fondateur effectivement
prononcé par le président la république
sous la coupole de l'institut de france
et bien c'est un foisonnement
d'initiatives et d'actions qui ont vu le
jour
parlons moyens budgétaires nous sommes
passés tout simplement de 97 millions
d'euros octroyée au soutien au système
éducatif dans les pays en développement
parce que nous avons besoin pour que le
français soit une réalité non pas
seulement une potentialité et bien que
nous puissions accompagner ces systèmes
éducatifs un budget de 208 millions
d'euros en 2018 et nous allons
l'accroître pour passer à 300 millions
d'euros
par ailleurs il y à une synergie des
actions conduites aussi avec
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie le président de la
république a pu évoquer ces sujets hier
en rencontrant la nouvelle secrétaire
générale madame louise mushikiwabo
et tout cela va se décliner au sein des
institutions européennes pour que le
français soit toujours plus et mieux
enseigner aux fonctionnaires
internationaux parce que il est
essentiel pour que l'europe soit une
réalité également que le multilinguisme
soit une réalité concrète et qu'on
puisse s'y exprimer en français
s'agissant des volontaires
internationaux une idée qui avait
d'ailleurs été mis sur la table par
joëlle garriaud-maylam nous en sommes au
stade de l'expérimentation mais nous
entendons bien passé au stade de
l'industrialisation si je puis dire
ainsi par ailleurs hier avec frédéric
vidal nous posions la première pierre
d'une maison des étudiants de la
francophonie au sein de la cité
internationale
elle va pouvoir accueillir 150 étudiants
francophones en 2020 et ça sera un lieu
naturellement d'inspiration et puis vous
l'avez dit les campus
le campus franco-sénégalais le campus
franco tunisien tous ces chantiers
avancent bien et je sais que c'est un
sujet qui rassemble largement
j'ai d'ailleurs une pensée pour jacques
legendre et michel andré qui ont porté
haut cette flamme et que nous nous
attachons à perpétuer ensemble en ce que
vous ayez
monsieur lune et se j'entends la liste
de désordre sont engagés je reste en
tous les cas le témoin sur le terrain
dans des cages de réelle entre les
discours et les cotisations alors nous
attendrons les mois qui viennent pour
voir la traduction d'une façon générale
je pense que même sous la coupole de
l'institut de france
ils peuvent parfois avoir dit ce couple
modeste des engagements qu'ils soient
tenus
merci